une production du studio sfr a mené au
sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités
baptiste super gigandet mois de dôme
plan cette semaine sans filtre est
présenté par ce tram ce tram cd pareil
en acier inoxydable comme j'ai dans mes
mains en ce moment chaque jour dans le
monde ces 500 millions de pas de
plastiques sont utilisés c'est une scène
puis il ya des habitudes de vie qui sont
vraiment plus difficiles à changer que
d'autres mais de commencer à traîner des
petites folles comme ceux qui sont
esthétiques qui sont super pratique dans
votre sacoche dans votre sac ou même
dans votre pochette à l'intérieur de
votre baisse si vous portez veston ou à
l'erreur vos poches sont ou dans le fond
ça c'est vraiment simple a changé en
termes d'habitudes puits dans fonds
ce tram nous ont rejoints pour comme
commandité le podcast puis on est
vraiment reconnaissant parce que
s'associer avec des trucs qui fit avec
avec nos valeurs avec qu'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire le plus possible dans
notre vie c'est à dire réduire
tranquillement notre empreinte plus
conscientisés par rapport à
l'environnement
on est super content de sa c6 r extrême
et en plus les pas ils viennent en
plusieurs couleurs comme dit si on
dirait que c'est on dirait que c'est
spécialement pour la praille de couleurs
de l'arc en ciel qui viennent avec ce
pays ils viennent aussi avec des ans
plusieurs formes avec moi d'un petit
machin fans à voter car en étant à
taïwan je consommais du beau petit de
façon excessive à peu près 4 beauvau
puis par jour pièces et des grosses pas
comme ça pour des smoothie ou pour des
bobos petit si vous êtes comme moi vous
aimez les bobos
[Musique]
sinon y'a comme un espèce de petite
affaire pour les ramener pour les laver
vraiment facilement c'est super simple
et des petites pochettes pour les
promener avec vous honnêtement ce tram
c'est de la bombe
si vous utilisez le code promo sans
filtre vous avez 15 % de rabais lors du
ch et 86 vous cliquez sur le lien rabais
boîte automatique être automatiquement
installés sur votre commande donc le
lien dans la gestion de la vidéo
merci à ce tram pour cette commandite le
yes bassiste
ils ont écrit sur ta g livebox et on
aime ce que vous faites ont vu vous
sponsorisés c'est si vous êtes une
entreprise vous avez un run sa vie
quelque chose que vous voulez qu'on vous
voulez nous sponsoriser dans le fond
qu'on en parle sur le podcast dans le
fond ça nous aide à vivre ça ne fait pas
résister quelque chose en plus qui est
qui
quiconque ont trop importants comme
comme comme ce fait que oui sinon cette
semaine ses six ans à venir
antoine olivier pilon qui est un acteur
comédien que vous connaissez le convoi
dans qu'on a vu de ce qui s'est fait
connaître surtout dans mon ami du grand
public le film de xavier dolan où il y
est absolument époustouflant excellent
incroyable s'inquiète d'autres films
junior majeur quelques autres anciens
aussi un goût j'ai été vraiment surpris
en fait je tombe carrément sur un gel de
la maturité de ce colloque je pense j'ai
commencé de gaza mais honnêtement c'est
incroyable parce que c'est quand même
condamné plus jeunes que nous petits et
moins me torche le niveau maturité puis
niveau conscient conditions personne
conscience représentent des consciences
et des relations avec les autres humains
autour de lui puis d'aider comment bien
s'exprimer aux gens combien bien
communiquer dessus c'est quelque chose
qui vraiment travaillé pour sa part
rappelé que c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment réfléchi beaucoup mais quand on
a beaucoup dit ça a été vraiment vite
pris cette direction là la conversation
sur les relations interpersonnelles et
comment vraiment c'est tellement mieux
communiquer puis finalement été ma
meilleure personne mais aussi de cinéma
on a parlé de ses rôles pitt son métier
dit mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce qu'ils recherchent adam qu'est
ce qu'ils aiment dans son métier une
grande rencontre un coq j'adorais
vraiment trippé sur sa gueule tu as que
certains vous allez très près de 12
on est vraiment privilégié à chaque
semaine un ch'ti belles rencontres à
chaque fois s'il meurt c'est qu'on évite
les des gens qu'on admire qui nous
inspire on trouvait intéressant
puis à chaque fois en plus après une
conversation comme ça on y trouve dix
fois plus intéressant qu'on pensait
qu'il y est c'est fait
c'est vraiment enrichissant pour tout à
fait sinon vous nous écoutez en ce
moment sur youtube sur balado
abonnez-vous à notre champ laissé des
commentaires participer à la discussion
aussi vous avez sans doute entendu
parler des jeunes notre projet du studio
au cf qu'on a lancé la semaine passée
avec jay du temple vous avez déjà des
podcasts s'ils sont disponibles
le temps des jujubes avec adamo whisky
adamo il prend jugent que voter hc puis
discute avec des artisans de la scène
hip hop puis éventuellement des artistes
en général
ensuite j'ai du temps tu discutes qui
est sorti probablement si vous écoutez
ce mardi c'est sorti hier j'ai du temps
on discute ce qui est du temps qu'ils
s'assoient puis qui discute ça porte
bien son nom abonnés voir c'est celle là
aussi rester à l'affût parce que si vous
aimez le contenu podcast si vous écoutez
en ce moment j'imagine que c'est parce
que vous aimez ce il va en avoir de la
grande qualité qui va sortir du fcc
garantie et puis sinon vous aime toutes
la gagne puis c'est ça fait que bon
broadcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
et c'est merci d'être là notre nouveau
studio télé où pamiers qu'on enregistre
avec là on espère ça va bien se passer
pour des vierges de studio déviance est
idiot exact on vient de se faire quatre
coachs hot c'est que les 1,6 milliard
d'affichages pour pour le tri à faire
savoir que c'était devenu un peu plaisir
merci de l'habitation
c'est ça fait extrêmement plaisir tu dis
que c'est écouter des podcasts moyens
pleinement ouais de plus en plus
belgique où la majorité de tout le monde
cependant sinon ouais j'ai cru un peu
léger pas trouvé beaucoup de personnes
mais j'aime ce explorer soir plus
justement puisqu'elle joue votre
invitation je trouve ça intéressant
l'enfant parties dans leurs caisses que
caisse maintenance et qui sait de quoi
est il plus ternes et les entrevues
traditionnel moutons parce que quand tu
fais la tournée médiatique pour pour peu
importe c'est quoi tes projets j'imagine
qui a mené à des questions c'est comme
très rapides souvent comme deux minutes
puis on va être le réalisateur puis
trois acteurs du film dans une dans un
petit studio radio on va être reçue
pilote dans ce même journal on en a
peut-être six radios différentes qu'on
va faire donc on a des segments de deux
minutes même pas fac-ci souvent juste
les gros les grosses lignes non malte où
puis je trouve ça l'fun des fois
justement moi les entrevues ou est-ce
que c'est plus détendu un peu où est-ce
qu'on a plus d'espacé à sortir des
sentiers battus des centaines
d'auditions les deux centraux tt ça
parce que justement c'est victor venait
lécher qu'imputer mettons sur youtube
j'étais jeune ça va entendre ben longue
entrevue lui et il entend parler un peu
plus
je n'ai pas vraiment trouvé exact toi
c'est quand et comment ces actes et
quand j'ai déménagé à montréal à l'âge
de 11 ans environ
chénard montréal mais j'ai grandi en
gaspésie away ou là par daniel simba
dans la baie des chaleurs
vitaly faire un show de l'été sans porc
d'agneau ap à lanières en
on était de passer devant la maison
parce que j'ai grandi sur mer s'est
agitée pas d'accord ouais mon village
c'est bon mais en fait on est exposé je
jouais dehors dans le festival sur
bordeaux avec avec ma blonde qui
pleuvaient
je voulais avec le pire acoustique des
lycées les collèges était malade ça a
été écoute
ouais ok mais voit sa bouille large la
prochaine en gaspésie c'est avec enfants
on y re venu mourir à montréal après
puis à partir de là je serais déjà en
fait je sors je sais pas depuis l'âge de
8 ans peut-être je sais que je veux
faire ce j'avais déjà vu des enfants
dans des émissions comme une grenade
avec ça
toutefois un trouble que j'ai écouté
religieusement pis je vais vu un enfant
mon appareil dont ils ont besoin les
kinois faire celui et la demande à nos
parents puis on était comme à 10 heures
de montréal fait que ce n'est pas
l'idéal pour des auditions
puis la belle faut qu'on a déménagé on a
commencé à manger vargo j'ai écrit
comment devenir acteur au québec dans
ces contrées des agences de talents au
québec dit il
les prochaines éditions pour entrer dans
la chanson telle date par exemple
ouverte au public leur part lentement en
publierons nos masseurs qui est à
refaire on y voit ma soeur et moi qui ai
lu si vous la forcez puis la barre me
fait une condition pour l'agencé a
fonctionné à partir de là le nous ont
donné les auditions pour des projets
voilà c'était quoi l'argent l'agent ceux
qui mouillent premiers rôles mais à
partir de là les auditionner je décroche
un rôle pour frisson des collines
ouais
puis à partir de ça comme vous voulez
les ultimes portes et autres audi aussi
après ça ça a été déviée qui m'ont écrit
pour laurence anyways une petite
apparition qu'à bruxelles a écrit pour
la vidéo club ados chine corée du boys
qui pendant un tournage de ce rallye des
documents mais aussi piteux spots et
comment on s'entend je pense qu'il m'a
vu dans les collines qui m'avait trèbes
et utah
[Musique]
j'avais 13 ans maintenant et je veux
dire j'emmène ma vie en fait je pense
qu'il y avait ce que j'avais fait
il m'a quand même fait un petit rôle
dans la scène où est gérée points
communs chips à la peau fait correct
mais quand même si le fait qu'il est
quand même assez connu à l'époque xavier
puis qui m'écrivent rail avaient été
connus avant mobile dès son premier film
en fait il était connu puis les cuts qui
m'écrivent qui m'écrivent pour m'offrir
la fuite avait été créé à toi
personnellement non j'en suis à mon
agente l ena qui avec qui lui a
travaillé aussi qu'elles étaient
plongées dans le noir bleuté encore avec
cette agente le jour est-ce que ça a été
depuis le début quand il parle de
l'argent ce quiz des postes et reçus
c'est vrai non non j'ai switché par la
suite
elena en fait était une amie à mon père
je présente elle aussi je pense que
depuis amman et on a décidé de tout
simplement changer de direction puis
puis elena qu'il est libre devant ouvert
ma soeur et moi un pilote ça fait peu
près dix ans
c'est au dessus parce qu'ils d'avoir une
relation avec avec un agent ou nageant
avec qui tu peux faire 100% confiance
c'est tellement nécessité d'importants
la transparence luthiste une équipe plus
proche un peu si c'est du foot et du
timor qui qu'ils soient constants puis
puis voilà communication aussi super
important ouais vraiment nous à thiais
maroc mort d'un agent qui marchait que
nous pour plusieurs plusieurs dossiers
les pieds
quand on parle d'un projet maintenant on
parle aux olympiens ouais parce qu'il
fait partie de ceux ci on a de l'argent
déboursé pour un investissement ils
veulent mettre avec gasquet c'est quand
même un pc sont aussi qu' on n'a pas
besoin de dobo checker ce qui lui fait
prendre comme décision met en confiance
et ça ce qui est une bonne affaire parce
que sinon tu t'en sors pas le fait qu'en
tant que citoyen ça va faire bientôt un
an
enfin ces exactions portée provenant
construit à mm on est amis mais prendre
en compte ce grade et alice en cette
relation là mais si c'est nécessaire
puis ça parlait de paul c'est toi juste
tout positif est juste écrire à l écran
10 m3 savons pas plaisir mais et crise
et à elle pour gérer ce puits ça enlève
mène une charge de travail énorme
ça permet de concentrer sur ce que toi
tu le feras pauvre exact explosive et
aussi d'aider des confusions ça et que
ça peut éviter des problèmes des
mauvaises adresses soudan réseau peu
importe le défaut lors des journées qui
sont super charger fait que j'ai parlé
ça maintenant de vérifier ou préparant
ses six mois sa retraite avec quelques
jours par les puits soit à l'heure avec
telle affaire habitué des fois j'ai plus
de temps où m il ya des gens que je
connais super bien qu'ils me demandent
pour un truc peu importe comme mon ami
ben dunne st jacques qui fait son job
série le probatoire ce qui reçoit déjà
en voiture puis les interviews pile
puis je me suis lié d'amitié avec banane
puis j'ai pas demandé passé nous avons à
mon âge war sa place quand la liberté
oui intervention exact c'est vraiment
une
c'est un essentiel surtout pour
quelqu'un qui oeuvre dans le domaine
artistique
parce que tu veux te concentrer à faire
le jeu balle en touche pas
nécessairement mon exemple - mais c'est
que toi j'imagine que tu te concentres à
apporter la meilleure qualité de projets
possibles chaque fois qu'ils sont mariés
dans quelque chose de dire parce que tu
serais pas vendu ou est ce que tu t'es
rendu cette abarth et basse
le club a comme d'abord aux qui permet à
toi de te concentrer sur ce we dernier
d'aller de l'avant vers des trucs ça t
la paperasse mais non ma part louis paul
la paperasse les cieux passer ses
journées à répondre à des mails si la
fesa plus anti créative ouest avec ce
qui si on est capable de trouver un peu
de nous concentrer sur créé par mu
vraiment c'est ça l'esprit mon chemin
qui m'avait donné de conseil le
rapidement sorte en occupation double et
mosimann trouve-toi nageant que tu veux
rester puis le 15 à 20% qui va prendre
il va te le ramener en double c'est rien
ça comme paul c'est ça devrait pas être
dans l'équation était de dire ah non le
mot jouer si je dois faire 20% de plus
loin mais premièrement il est déjà forte
tu feras pas pendant que tu riche pas
nécessairement deuxièmement toi
j'imagine que tu es si je t'écris à toi
je te fais un est-ce que tu veux faire
partie de mon projet quelles sont tes
tarifs toi parle par les mettre en
valeur ses toiles s'élargissent époque
je sais pas non plus seulement comme
évaluer un projet de tour est-ce que ça
vaut qui je veux pas être le gars qui
propose un prix placé mais là c'est cher
un cinéma aussi bien télévision tu sais
pas comme un montant festive des droits
de suite dit si tu as des idées sopi ça
peut être vraiment compliqué le rapport
mais est-ce que question soit libre de
répondre ou non le mais les cachets c
est ce que c'est une négocier ça aussi
c'était le cas chez potel fait mme dati
depuis oui ou non jamais nommé après ce
le fameux minimum de survie passe mal je
pense quand même ce qu'il mange sur le
film de pascale il dit doit être payé
sur le cash et déjà je fais même pas ce
que j'aurais fait gratuitement puisque
les mêmes amis du café c'est le frère de
dom il réalisa temps un qui est un film
que c'est ce qui s'appelle pascal plante
c'est lui qui l'a dit les faibles
niveaux tatouages merci merci merci je
crois culture et puis tourner à notre
concept et qui se porte à l'univers de
la natation dans le fond fait que ouais
ça va s'appeler dans le fond ce film
s'appelle nadia barfly il ya quelques
acteurs dans le film et les actes et les
personnages principaux sont des noms
d'acteurs s'est dit l'ombre et qui sait
sa cdc livré nageuse de niveau qui est
allé chercher quelqu'un quand même
auditionné les a sélectionnés sauf que
dangereuses qui ont un naturel à la
caméra mettons fait que ces sites ont
cet été il valait félix en à tokyo parce
que ça se passe aux olympiques de tokyo
de 2020 que
[Musique]
folefack t il son premier film il y
avait quelques secondes métier c'était
vraiment un microbudget puis là c'est la
grosse en fait que c'est une existence
ok moi c'est ça c'est qui ça va être là
dessus avec luther non non on travaille
souvent ensemble pour des projets vidéo
mettons que j'ai besoin justement de
taima blonde sur la musique fait
quelqu'un besoin d'un vidéaste en
alphabet toujours mon frère mais sinon
son film non c'est celui et c'est celui
de son équipier ça vole bas ça c'est que
je voulais mon rôle à un scénario ses
nageurs sommes francophones numéro un de
la page imdb de mont-wright et sur quels
projets en ce moment j rapper sur rap
hip hop rap y est j'ai regardé sur la
ramenant de coriaces j'ai pour leur
appui sur un film qui s'appelle des
saveurs les dix semaines écrit un
scénario de matt bissonnette qui était
qui était quand même ses proches de
l'honneur cohen
c'était un gamin à montréal et
anglophones qui maintenant habitent à
los angeles puis connaissait leonard
cohen
je pense qu'il avait rencontré sa fille
peut-être enfin pop il oeuvre nos mains
ils sont rencontrés sont bien peu
d'amitié toupie avait fait un
documentaire un petit documentaire je
pense sur lui et mais quand être
étudiant un peu puis il ya commencé à
écrire ce scénario lot des civils et
guzman qui serait franchement au-dessus
de 6 ans le kit scénario puis on en
connaît beaucoup beaucoup apprécié je
pense scénario est le lieu où elle a lu
beaucoup de ceux qui comme lui libérer
toutes ces droits des chansons pour alma
dans le scénario est afin qu'ils
essaient depuis j'attends vos chances
mahatma d'approché à peu près
quatre ans je pense pour ce qui est de
3,4 pour faire l'enfant le scénario
s'est inspiré des oeuvres de léonard
cohen qui on suit un prof de poésie à
l'université que dans la cinquantaine à
peu près deux enfants une fille et un
garçon et c'est à son ex femme avec qui
réussit des enfants l'aquitaine
montréalaise donc un peu comme le leur
copine puis moi je fais le garçon degrés
sur le principal qui je parle a dit
gilbert et l'irlande est sous verre puis
dit je l'entends difficile c'est sûr que
je vois ça fasse ce qu'il trouve trop vu
ce qui est de ce fait à fond chez moi
j'ai comme change wardak il a des
cheveux sont inquiétants puis j'ai connu
des jours de tournage à peu près le cas
pour le finisseur s'écoule ensuite les
fans puis à la fin de cette année si yo
le film gotham sting qui devrait sortir
sur lequel j'ai travaillé l'année
pensent il s'agit et josh hartnett
jardin quand même le ségala même des
bitumes et l'est étaient au top là qui
vient à l'époque il fallait pas qu'ils
viennent qu'à ranger ses grandes
comédies romantiques le sait je pensais
vraiment le 2000 2011 avec la fille qui
joue dans le chevalier avec les amoureux
et qu'il n'y a pas le droit d'être
heureux de venir dans le fond par ses
amis il même dans les pires situations
ski ses amis ont comme parier que lui
allait pas capable avec l'aide d'un pire
situation sera plus fm le quai comme qui
devenu comme elle l'est c'est sympa
c'est ben je pense que je pense que josh
il ya eu un des leurs la première répète
qu'on est en somme c'était à bangkok
parce qu'on commençait à la partie du
tournage là bas
puis on ne répète avec daniel roby le
réseau orpi et autant de films et josh
moi je ne sais pas encore tout à fait
mon texte à ce moment le procès le plus
qu'est-ce qui lui valent connaît déjà
par quand je suis pas professionnel
mais j'adore la carte devant lui pour
franchir cette histoire c'est une ligne
c'est un non sens personnes déjà
s'étaient vraiment relax qui me répète
le pigment brisé la glace en deux puis à
pisser s'apprécier comme de ce que j'ai
compris en jeu un peu avec lui camus je
pense des trucs qui sont passés avec
soit des agents ou des gens du milieu là
bas le sens du respect comme décidé de
sortir un peu de tout ce monde le tout
un système qui avec lequel il connecte
pas tout je pense et puis un millier
parti est sortie d'aly état les valeurs
avec sa femme qu'il ya eu il ya eu un
enfant récemment puis parce qu'il y en a
deux puis c'est quand même un peu
déconnecté de 10h05 - pas rue parce que
si c'était comme l'hyper ashton kutcher
les deux les uns comme les deux les deux
autres il avait revêti je pense y avait
été choisi pour faire superman jonathan
viacom a refusé puis c'est ce qui a fait
en sorte qu'ils aient des gens qu'ils
ont comme boycotter je sais pas trop à
qui ce flou j'avais imaginé que ça doit
un esti de domaine des milieux à ce
lourd bien plus malsain des fois la
hollywood du labeur je commence à comme
gardien plus y croire mais j'imagine que
oui comme dans n'importe quel domaine un
peu aussi le toit ce qui est tensions
qui peuvent être différents lobbys mal
intentionnés mais où que beaucoup de
l'adage il a beaucoup d'argent je puis
de de réputation à garder puis de le bon
choix faire qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
pourtant dimanche que ce qui pour bon
mais tout commence à développer petit
feu un peu en fait tu veux moi
j'aimerais carrière ascendante
j'aime avoir l'opportunité de voyager en
travaillant ça fout
j'adore ce travail au québec les gens
ici sont tellement tarata moi je me
livre d'amitié avec avec les gens sur
les plateaux puis ça fait en sorte que
je travaille encore mieux je pense
puis je revois des gens qui j'ai
travaillé à le penser aussi qui montent
comme un peu même si on veut menteur et
il a autant les comédiens que des gens
derrière la caméra puis puisque j'aime
ce travail avec les recroise au québec
et tout mais certains participants qui
ont envie d'aller aux états unis voici
comment travailler sur un set là bas et
c'est travailler en anglais aussi pu
briser un peu ccc borias de briser les
douanes sont vu le niveau de la création
cinématographique
c'est de plus en plus on voit des
québécois qu'ils font c'est fini ça
fonctionne qu'après on peut regarder
juste éclairé al wassit céréales
québécois qui ont les clés de lewa de
maintenant jean marc vallée de cinq ans
faute aussi au québec dès qu'il faisait
bon - six éléments qui font qu'ils
travaillent sur beaucoup de projets puis
on sera pas nécessairement grand mais si
les québécois puis c'est super cool
j'écoutais en entrevue qu d'alfaro qui
parlait de justement on parlait de leweb
du camas à petit ça peut être un milieu
qui est rofl puis lui il disait mon son
premier film son cachet tête 200000 d'or
puis son deuxième film
ces genres 3.8 millions c'est comme ça
comme exploser ses affaires si son agent
mais ça comme explosé quand qui est
arrivé à aller world qui était jeune
puis après ça vite après il a fait le
film miami heat quai puis il dit je me
rappelle pas du 7 me rappelle pas du
tournage de sumela j'étais complètement
défoncée pendant tout laisse tout le
temps aurait pu le faire
il y avait qu'une même pendant qu en
trois ans la neige on sait tous leurs
droits et variés tels buvait
même à droite apogée il fait qu'ils se
rappellent pas de son tournage demi
américain qui en parlent ils y posera
aux mnt les bonnes années se défoncer ea
com même si j'allais j'allais pas bien
il dit
j'arrive dans un milieu je suis jeune je
suis good rockin tout le monde veut il
dire piece of me fait que tout le monde
veut qu'il faut pour dire qu'il faut
pour le tout le monde veut que choix a
été porté à telle place plan mené du 3
mars puis de pause qu'il faut pour gérer
ce que leur ai dit tu les chefs combler
ceux qui luttent pour ce cas précis et
c'est comme iggy comme disparus
hollywood un peu comment parler des
trottoirs n'a disparu de l'airé du
cancer faire des films indépendants
irlandaise que justin irlandais et
comique à retourner chez eux une coupe
de films indépendants et jean le hir
commencé à faire une coupe de films
c'est à gauche des blockbusters c'est
sûr que quand on cachait pas 200 milles
à 3.8 millions de 10 bars et quelque
chose comme cela peu près sûr que
l'emploi de ce projet là j'ai
l'impression que vient avec le cachet
oui c'est sûr qu'on paye tel nombre de
millions de dollars parce que tu vas
avoir une visibilité incroyable donc une
pression plus forte de la part du public
des produits nobles avril où c'est sûr
que ce défaut c'est un peu difficile de
garder le cap le mal passée perdent là
dedans c'est maintenant que mettons
qu'on comprend ton exemple plus petite
échelle c'est que kankan momie arrive le
blesser comme ok jour au lendemain je
passe d'un acteur que de la job qui
travaille à un acteur qui s'en va car ce
que commencent commande commande suivi
se dit comment comment tu vis et comment
ça c'est que c'est comment c'est
peut-être ce passage là parce que chez
chez qui ça doit être étourdissant
l'impression ouais ouais totalement ça
c'est fait du bien j'ai envie de très
bien
j'ai trouvé ça difficile à certains
moments parce que c'est une fois que
comme un mouton que j rich se piquent
leur avec ma main avec moi ma
performance aussi dans le film et tout
comme un 5e match sans pression lincecum
d'enfants durable surgissait pour faire
mieux
qu'est ce que je fais pour ses camps
bascule à partir de ce projet là les
gens vont toujours fermé
la dame est comme quand tu ne travailles
encore un peu mais ils pourront jamais
faire quelque chose d'aussi bons que
maintenant que de ce qui vient signer en
tête puis qui tard mais qui remettra
confiance en question est aussi juste de
vivre à cannes pendant une semaine
provenant des rock stars
déjà que j'avais testé déjà très connu
là bas un pile avec ce film les gens de
leurs voix étaient super contents mais
ça peut jeter qui met une fois que le
film a été vu là-bas assez mal les gens
ils sont foule c'est horriblement son
meilleur film
d'ailleurs tu lis tous ces thèmes sont
bons mais celui là leur seul dit il ya
quelque chose de spécial vraiment y
avait une
mais bon hein c'est spécial c'est olp
s'est apprécié de suivi tout ce buzz
lorsque tous les jours qu'il faisait au
moins dix fois que les gens aiment et
ont travaillé une fois tu fais tout
compte fait le site précis sur le sort
de ce fait la fête du plaisir de trouver
leurs mains entrevue un quart du match
par bien boire gratuitement qu'après ce
tu reviens et montréal maintenant je
trouvais la montreal après puis puis
après ça c'est comme ok c'est quoi soit
6 n'excuse pas le cas on le sait comme
l'objectif de tellement de réseaux tant
dans leur vie par exemple ou d'acteurs
le moment donné le géorgien mort à
brusquer works et secom ça manque des
jeunes jeux des jeux j'ai envie de
revivre ce petit jeu c'est parce qu'ils
en vivent une autre fois dans ma vie
j'en aucune des mets
c'est de judo comme fer merci pour sûr
maintenant faut que je m'en débarrasse
puis comme je pense à autre chose parce
que si je reste pas ni là dedans c'est
pas ça peut être très négatif si je
pense s'est classé clamait encore là par
exemple une carrière c'est long quand il
pleut tellement il se fait tellement
voire un million de bourreau ou encore
de l'homme était ici sortie de vivre sa
séance extraordinaire
j'essaie dé nature et aussi je pense que
je pense que ça peut être super déco
pour un enfant est certaine à jean bodin
certain âge de vivre des expériences
comme ça mais j'étais super bien entouré
tout au long de ma carrière avant
d'arriver là et là bas aussi avec les
gens qui nous entourent et fait que ce
ça a été un gros plus penser à ça ça va
peut-être tough dans tous les les
milieux artistiques d'atteindre 1 aussi
au smic ce puits après ce qu'est ce tu
flippes qui c'est quoi le raisonnement
pour te dire ok je vois faire de quoi
sachant probablement pertinemment que ça
ce rapport à ce niveau là ce sera pas
reçu de la même façon les tiges pensa il
ya plusieurs raids si on en parlait avec
patrick senécal de stéphane larue enfin
eric est un auteur qui fait un livre
s'appelle le plongeur son premier roman
c'est un succès phénoménal au québec
tout le monde est bandé sur le plongeur
toulon entend dans toute l'école de
littérature on parle du plongeur tout le
monde capote le stéphane larue qui est
pas une hauteur qui était pas une
hauteur avant ce livre bleu qui était un
barman qui travaille en restauration qui
explique leur loto morricone ok mais ton
2eme et qui sait qu'à qui arrive pile
aussi je sais pas par où le prendre mais
le deuxième cas mathieu que comment tu
veux que dans ma tête personnage sache
que était si ces reçus mieux que le
plongeur même thé dansant dans les rues
citées mais ces études citées les
chances que ça arrive
j'ai envie d'enfin 2 m moi je pense
qu'il est en train d'en écrire mais mais
c'est tout comme
comment te réussit à atterrir ok
j'accepte ce qui a mené le prochain
projet
je le pense je n'en vois ce maître pâton
100 % dans le projet tu sais de façon
cartésienne que cissé reçu comme momies
bâtiment ccn singleton puis 3 dis que
j'ai fait avant mamie jeu le junior
majeur
la suite qui est arrivé après mon métier
je savais très bien embarqué sur junior
majeur que c'était pas le genre de film
qui va chercher là qu'il est bien
évidemment tu es mais j'ai quand même eu
un plaisir énorme à fabien major puis je
voulais quand même le faire sachant que
ça allait pas avoir subi je pense et
c'est à ce moment là je me suis posé la
question en fait pourquoi je fais des
films
est ce que c'est pour me rendre à cannes
comme ce que c'est ce que je puis le mon
objectif
les prochaines fois que j'embarque sur
un projet c'est juste pour revivre ce
que j'ai vécu avec mamie ou au contraire
moins que j'ai réalisé que pourquoi je
faisais des films ce parce que sur
l'ambiance sur le plateau de tournage
c'est ce qui me fait rire permet de
travailler avec une équipe de 30
personnes et plus
puis ou moins pipi que tout le monde a
son rôle pour créer un produit comme ça
qui part d'une idée qui sur papier qui
ensuite on arrive à le mettre à l'écran
on peut partager à tout le monde fait
revivre des émotions jamais c'est moi ce
que j'ai compris que je voulais faire
puis puis des fois tu tombes sur des
projets qui qui sont moins agréables que
d'autres ou des photos remet sur un
projet qui est encore plus agréable que
tu possible qui me sentir encore mieux
que je pensais
puis je me suis dis ça juste pour la
question pourquoi je fais ça pis c'est
vraiment pour être sur des plateaux de
tournage j'ai dit c'est que j'aime c'est
vraiment ce un petit des foyers des
scénarios qu'ils veulent ils que haye
après la fois que je changerais que je
pense que c'est possible ou pas mais moi
ce que ça va apporter à travailler sur
ce film là c'était malade j'ai rencontré
telle ou telle personne qui sont des
supers bons amis aujourd'hui je
rencontre est-elle real qui lui
peut-être que dans cinq ans il va
refaire un film puis comme on travaille
ensemble on pense à moitié on sait
jamais c'est aussi ce qui a un coût du
travail pour que ça engendre d'autres
choses c'est ce temps le rôle parfait
comme les utilise en rêvant de longtemps
a jamais offert les éditions qui vont
être déçus parce que ça n'a pas
fonctionné mais moi ça m'est déjà arrivé
de faire une édition pour un projet ça
peut marcher si le gars qui maudissent
yonnais belle 8 e sur un autre projet
puis à fait
que tout ce que tu as fait le ca marche
pas pour ça mais mais moi je te refais
le rôle pour ce montant parce que je
t'ai vu le phare le tout puis ça marche
le pire que je n'ai tellement d'autres
acteurs kick cannes en ligne de compte
peu juste le talent qui fait porter
pâles rôle c'est vraiment la fin des
castings souvent d'enfants totalement
des looks dit marc défossez l'autre
personnes qui ont choisi en premier ben
c'est autour de cette personne mais
qu'il faut construire le reste du
casting
il est dommage parce qu'ils étaient
super bon mais deux rôles de s'asseoir
métaux c'est soit ça c'est fou si on
prend 4 mai 14 simoni peuvent s entre
les mains tu imagines que tu lis ça
qu'ils ont notre g de lard témoigne un
flash de charge un parc pas trop loin de
chez moment où j'habite à l'époque puis
xavier dans son scénario de momies puis
dans la magie scénario s'il ya souvent
des chansons déjà en tête qui ont
utilisé pour la cette séquence le par
exemple puis j'écris des chansons de
l'artiste commence à jouer pilotes comme
la grossesse khaliki qui expliquait ce
convoi pillière qui je les mettais dans
mon cellulaire puisse écouter petit est
une super bonne trame un standard
malines a marre et j'ai écouté puis
s'est couché dans le parc en alsace et
pis j'ai tellement excité le deuil six
se faisait mentir maginez la scène avec
la musique plus et ça va être bien
rotem dire qu'il y en a cinq ou six
parce qu'il est en train d'écrire le
scénario pire on s'en parle et puis me
disaient que leur entente ginseng
lorsqu'ils attaquent site avec ta mère
pile ce panier d'ensemble tête envoie
chier taxi m'a fait super à 6 pi du
crash aux taxis du monde soutien aux
plus exceptionnels
à quoi ça va ressembler main qui on
faire si dieu nous sommes dans un
bosquet du groupe des deux matches nuls
qui irrite warp et ou bla bla pileux
c'est comme le rôle parfait parce que
tel éventail des émotions au complet se
passe par tout s'est vraiment c'est
ultra t'acharnes c'est vraiment ce
pauvre est alors ma droite les
producteurs de bonbons ce qui est
précieux de jumelés à des actrices comme
suzanne clément qui est normal
c'est incroyable c'est ses deux fils
sont tellement fines qui sont tellement
l'amour avec le travail qu'ils font
puis c'est ce qu'ils font c'est de
rencontrer d'autres personnes qui sont
passionnés par ce son qui sort trop
plein de personnes qui sont passionnés
par ce par ce milieu là puis on
travaille ensemble pour faire le mieux
qu'on peut
un xavier si le passionné des passionnés
le disque gênante de ce que j'ai entendu
lui c'est de travailler à la sienne à
lallange s'essayer passionnés piller je
trouve assez duo six mois ci il lit
beaucoup il va faire des recherches
il est et il va pas jusque hommes
démontré sa passion fasciné mollet va
vraiment comme est recalé le tibre il va
regarder et regarder certains films il
va aller lire sur les personnes qu'ils
ont écrit les sur les acteurs et tous
extrêmement qui le suivait la dent j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour ce que je
trouve ça vraiment impressionnant ça
paraît ça paraît certaine façon dans ses
films c'est le travail le travail de
données servant de recherche mais juste
de passion de connaître son or c'est de
connaître lors d'enquêtés dévolu je
pense c'est capital si nécessaire
j'ai entendu une énorme cinéphiles ces
gaulois se serait toujours aussi un jour
puis non vraiment ça transparaît dans
ses films qui ces mamies bien que ce
soit une situation extrême c'est un cas
extrême mais c'est quand même crédit
malgré ce très crédible à oui et puis
croissant baril et que moi j'ai eu des
témoignages par après ce fameux leurs
devoirs des dames qui travaillent sur ce
puits il me disait il dit
j'en ai trois des garçons comme ça je
travaille
puis c'est la première fois que je vois
un film mais ce que ça en est exactement
nécessairement qu'est ce qui se passe
avec avec l onm m et 1,10 et parfois je
vois film moi ce que je peux donner un
exemple de ce que je vis mon travail un
jour c'est difficile c'est vraiment ces
gens comprennent pas tout le temps mais
l'outil au moins j'ai un film que je
peux leur montrer d'autant moins
affectés le film devient un outil pas
dégagé quasiment huawei pipi que dd
d'environnement comme ceux qui dealent à
la dose d'amour que je ressens aucun
je peux te parler leur pivot est ce que
tu as fait dans le film ça me fait
tellement du bien merci pour ce billet
je pensais à ce moment là aussi que j'ai
réalisé que le cinéma plus tard on n'est
pas que positif sur les jeux wii qui
puissent devenir comme une référence un
peu pédagogique homme se dit la même
chose avec une 54 6 minutes 54 de yan'an
green qui était d'ailleurs le premier
projet que j'ai faits directement auprès
momie et qui traite l'intimidation
beaucoup de l'homosexualité du suicide
du si qui sont trop ce sujet que qui est
bon c'est un peu lourd quand même puis
ça peu tabou des fois mais des gens qui
sont venus qui nous ont écrit des gens
qui sont venus nous voir après pour me
dire à quel point ce à cause de ce film
l'heure les trois gars qui l'écart et à
l'école il y aurait été parce qu'ils se
rendent même pas compte qu'ils ont vu le
film dans fait ailleurs acquis engrangés
à l'école abbey lors on comprend qu'on
comprend c'est quoi ton point de vue à
toi me temps là dedans pis c'est quand
les gens me dire ça je trouve cela
vraiment agréable de voir l'impact que
cela peut avoir des passionnés par ce qu
on en a parlé avec différents cas meetic
sont ici catherine brunet heroes mari
d'ailleurs que le cinéma c'est lors de
deux lampes at il été justement ces
curistes
mais dans l'histoire si ce n'est à
planter personnage qui comprend la
réalité était un personnage comme dans
mamie c'est pas un personnage qui c'est
un personnage que tu te rends compte une
fois puis tu vas peut-être le détester
leurs potes mettra pas sa place à sera
pas de comprendre sa situation mais
quatre films de même c'est ok le petit
temps les petites crises la bce
il vit ces problèmes piliers ce que je
pourrais m'exprimer vous comprenez que
c'est d'avoir d'autres points de vue
tout simplement sacrément pipi puis moi
ce que j'aime aussi c'est de décider
d'appliquer dans la vie tous les jours
si vous rencontrez quelqu'un veut d'être
dans la rue le puits va être superbe et
avec tout le temps le fait ignorer mathy
sera pas correct me tall est au dessus
de sa veste et qui me tues tu l'avais
jamais rencontré a appelé ses copains et
telle personne le style bien je les
rencontrais tabarnak man méchante table
est mort à parler aux gens qui sait ce
que j'ai vécu avec toi mais tu auras ce
qui est pour
mais même temps je me base là dessus
aussi des gens qui vont être comme
québec mondiaux seront pas le goût que
moi je que noir puis à ce moment-là
peut-être que tu ne te faire persister
tu as eu de chance quelques envoyer
chier tu sais pas si c'était juste pour
réceptif à part les quelques heureux
tout simplement
c'est moi ça m'arrive des fois les gens
qui vont me rencontrer dans rue puis
j'ai d'avoir une ville de merde ou si ça
peut être n'importe quoi je peux pas
c'est quand même j'ai vraiment besoin
d'agir par espace à part des gens ce peu
importe c'est d'appliquer sur la vie de
tous les jours des postes basés sur des
fractions de secondes comme celui des
préjugés de rester jusqu'à un peu un
scénario six mois hier j'étais avec ma
soeur puis elle me racontait qu'à voyait
qu'un voyant go puis qui jouaient et
faisait un jeu et les deux ils
cherchaient du monde qui en un sens
commun sur google dit lama sera comme
dit je vais chercher sur google bing est
il devenu vraiment sérieux fait non non
fait pas ce danger ruch a joué quatre
fils heures à chercher sur google
trois jeux secs avec la nasa qu'en fait
de fautes flammes raconte c'est oui le
plus il m'a dit je m'en passerais
souplet plus m'asseoir par jeu allait
décider la guerre avec kita soir était
alors chercher du secours
voici ce que lui devenu super sérieux
maintenant on va supposer qu'ils veulent
non mais à 3 sur wii le masseur a dit et
je trouve ça drôle de m'imaginer que
n'importe quoi fait je vois pas le
google est sûr que moi mais ce qui est
dit hamdi le guèye était devenu super
oui et puis c'était vraiment bizarre
puis j'aurai comprenait pas trop puis
celle là me off un peu moi je veux
oublier que je veux pas entrer trop de
détails mais c'est quelque chose de
quand même sérieux laitiers c'est une
histoire de dire que on s'en parle mais
après je vous promettre que le maintien
histoire qui se finit médiatiquement
médiatiquement on en a parlé puis c'est
triste le secret sont très utiles puis
le gosse avait été si ma soeur avait lu
avec google et cette soirée la salle et
ruiné la soirée combien il serait allé
dans une zone qui voulait pas parler de
parler de quelque chose ça ait tenté pop
en tout cas les respecter c'est ça mais
pilotes massa comprenais pas mais elle
était comme fauche était off
le mot j'ai dit écoute marilou c'était
mieux pour tout le monde que ils
réagissent comme seul mais cette chose
le fait pas qu'est ce que l'oeil non
fréquentable non non non non pas
vraiment pas nous allons annoncer sa
réaction je la comprends vraiment
maintenant que j'ai c'est pourquoi tout
ça semble un petit peu à ce que tu dis
c'est quand il ya une réaction pas que
top de quelqu'un c'est pas de le juger
sur sa réaction le sûrement saas apporte
tout le temps de quelques ajustements
une réaction peu par hasard tu sais que
aulas il est déclenché par quelque chose
de peu importe sa part de quelques
passings et blessures ou à la vue est
tout c'est quelqu'un me ton si
j'accroche tombe à pic
ce plh par tous à terre droite gauche
c'est quelque chose qui appauvrit mandat
le ben moi je me dis à qui ça doit être
ça tombe sur moi me tomba j'ai fait un
accident mais se passe quelque chose
d'autre que moi en rapport avec moi
aussi ça rappe avec moi-même parlons-en
c'est souvent des pots de pâte à
matraquer moeurs les autres puis la
mesure les autres un peu le pied
s c'est vraiment une belle façon de
vivre ta ville ah ouais c'est bien ce
que toi tu dessus mais beaucoup moins de
pression aussi je pense a dit pourquoi
ils pourquoi il était comme ça que moi
c'est pourquoi même pas où il rêvait
études 6 pi cdc barentin avec les gens
je vais reprendre quand je trouve
quelqu'un qui m'aime pas chanter qui
essaie de comprendre pourquoi et tous
leurs api samad rennie tellement
d'énergie avec le temps c'est fou quand
a décidé d'arrêter faire si tu avais
plus cette espèce d'accord là dessus des
fois le même et ça a vraiment changé
avec les années mais c'est qu'après tu
dis tu peux pas plaire à tout le monde
peut juste pas pu
au lieu de mettre l'énergie là dessus
mais les neiges sur toi qui tu envie
d'être sur quotas qu'est ce que tu as
envie d'entreprendre que les gens qui
aiment ce pays qui sont passionnés par
ce soit ou qui sont à mi octobre les
attirer involontairement ils vont venir
dans ta vie c'est jean lou pitt sur
l'autre pour besoin de faire de travail
non seulement ce niveau là où peu
importe si je m'arrête plus sexy quand
est ce que le le premier travail est à
faire et surtout à 4,7 et relation cité
relations se répare pas par le travail
que tu fais sur toi là tu peux
travailler sur la relation mes premières
weiss a fait surtout officiel c'est
clair c'est clair c'est que ce soit les
amitiés à ton couple ou si un problème
première chose à l'examen deux c6 toi
moi même je pense et puis après c'est
comme tu dit si tu réussis à m'amener
ici si ton partenaire a vraiment des
problèmes il me ferait du bon père
répétition et c'est sûrement - ouais non
c'est sûr métiers cam et on met ça peut
partir de toits éventuellement s'appelle
dans n'importe quelle situation
ça peut vraiment répit puis des fois
juste de changer une petite affaire de
chez soi ça peut ça peut crissement
genre réparer des relations ou améliorer
vraiment des trucs pas que le pirate
prend la presse
molly jacques qui sont autour de moi que
j'aime beaucoup pis que je pense que
aussi même je vois je leur demandais je
dis à ces chants des fois ddt peut-être
pu fermer où chaque et quelque chose
c'est juste une part sensible joli
centre sud si la personne est la mal à
l'aise par un événement du passé ou prep
a tué 18 est ravie qu'on a parlé tout
puis le ben oui à qui je trouve que des
fois quand il fait tel truc gémit
ensuite accueilli jeudi à mener de
l'apathie à cette personne là parce que
justement déclenchée par quelque chose
que tu fais peut-être fait que tu viens
d'en parler c'est un super temps par
l'attitude sans jugement pee wee pipi ce
qui est bon aussi de souligner
l'intention avant tout mon intention
c'est d'être comme support à l'aise avec
tout ce qu'on a une bonne amie tifour
déconstruit
c'est ça mon intention 28 cents contre
une façon pour que ça marche en deux
tipis console en synergie de ces mon
intention c'est de continuer à tenir
parce que j'aime quand des livres pour
la liqueur et différenciante et mon
intention c'est d'être super aventure
mais qui parce que j'aime ce que tu fais
pipi je t'apprécie indice bel team dit
que ce soit par exemple de la difficulté
avec moi travaillons mais pour qu'on
puisse être capable d'être dans cette
invention ça ça fait partie de la
communication la communication c'est
tellement essentiel a tout pigé vraiment
l'impression que
que c'est c'est souvent sous-évalués
dans les interactions humaines en ce
moment est déjà aussi qui je pense ont
ont peut-être blessé par des trucs dû
penser ou des trucs qui sont arrivées
qui ont jamais pris le temps de soigner
puis ça ça va ça va les suivre toute
leur vie je pense en cimmérie animaux
sera pas là non je n'ai pas parlé de 65
pts qui manquait peut-être pas avec moi
pour le mais moi je pense que s'il faut
c'est inévitable de penser par ce
processus le si justement tu veux est
dans quelque chose de plus harmonieux
tout simplement tu peux ne pas vouloir
super et c'est la table c'est un chipset
à partie puis c'est pas nécessairement
mal mais moi je pense que oui quand il
quand même donc une relation avec ta
blonde on schématise amis peu importe la
famille ça va mal plus envie que ça
aille mieux bien saviez moi je pense de
blessures du passé qu'il faut que tu as
travaillé [ __ ] mettre le doigt dessus
puis exact le déni c'est une méthode
facile puis comme une direction qui
collectent piketty souvent j'imagine que
par un but ça peut être la seule option
possible parce que c'est trop duos aussi
imprécis pour l'instant mais justement
dans le long terme si tu viens jamais
rien rater c'est beau boulot pour lille
et paris
les crédits même physiquement le ça peut
venir
j'ai l'impression de ma vie d'avoir vécu
des événements particuliers qui m'ont
affecté le dos par exemple vraiment la
tasse pas dans l'eau ou aux ventes tout
simplement ou autre si c'est parce qu'il
ya une connexion entre toutes les
émotions qu'on vit avec notre corps
physique intéressant puis définitivement
le stress quel stress peut venir sur
plusieurs formes goûter un stress
émotionnel ça reste un stress
c'est un stress des relations de
tristesse de quelque chose qui est
présent sur toi ça peut être un stress
plus haut ça peut avoir un lieu un
événement traumatique montant exact je
suis d'accord peut sûrement voir un lien
avec avec des troubles physiques un
certain moment
un trend de thé bayeux encore un trend
qui dit tu es tout ce qui est toxique
dans ta vie élimine le pitou ski
négatives dans ta vie choc ne donne
depuis il malgré tout je trouve cette
action ce qui est toxique puisqu'il
négatif ou problématiques
et puis si les gens prennent le réflexe
de justes tout bloquer les émotions
négatives
les personnes qui croient être toxique
de leur entourage sans essayer de
comprendre pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que
c'est toxique pourquoi est ce que c'est
une justice tu te ramasses tu vieillis
plus tu ramasses à jamais avoir
confronté quelque chose de négatif
jamais avoir essayé de solutionner
quelque chose de négatif pleut je
prendrai le dire il ya des relations
clairement toxiques
mais si tu téléphones à voir pourquoi
exactement ce que non seulement à qui tu
leur as pu mettre un peu capables de de
repérer un autre genre de relation
toxique comme ceux qui veulent parce que
c'est ce à quoi de sa vie - feytiat déjà
toxiques y en a partout dans le monde
puis en bus à montréal autour de toi
dans ton entourage peu importe qui en
est ainsi je pense que ci dessus des
bases de lui aurait très bien joué tant
mieux si cette taxe est pour toi puis le
pur là-dedans parfait mais est ce truc
pourquoi parce que le il y en a d'autres
qui vont réapparaître manip qui sera pas
pourquoi tu sais de source
ma belle-mère à l'appel sur les antennes
de boule de neige les antennes de boules
de noël c'est maintenant c'est l'effet
boule de neige c'est quand des cinq
cours de tournage a grossi par amener à
devenir inarrêtable depuis les antennes
de boules à neige c'est ce qui te permet
de de voir quelque chose qui vaut 2 qui
pourrait avoir l'effet d'une boule de
neige puis de juste le quitter avant
voir des signes avant coureurs d'une
relation toxique mettons j'ai déjà vécu
ça par le passé j'ai réalisé qu est ce
qui me plaisait pas dans ce sens une
fois que c'était fermé puis l'a quand
même temps que tu une relation amoureuse
qui finit plus rencontre quelqu'un plus
cette personne ait fait quelque chose
qui qui te rappelle quelque chose que tu
sais que toi tu serais pas capable de
vivre avec carmen présent dès le début
imminent relation mais son club
oui c'est ça parce que sinon
ou sinon d'envol des marges ccct les
règles ni règle non écrite d'une
relation s'écrit vraiment au début a
agité la sphère piles aa m'a fait une
face ça fait six mois je l'aï dit on m'a
rien dit de la presse si moi je suis
comme ça aussi mais juste il espèce de
transe comme quelqu'un pileux il est
comme la période de limites sont où
qu'est ce qui te le redis ce n'était pas
le droit de dire puis le à m'amener la
dynamique s'installe puis ça reste
souple des faut surtout savoir une pente
descendante et des gens qui ont des
comportements de ces métaux et des
abuseurs ou des batteurs de femmes
ces premières journées que ça s'installe
tranquillement dans aucune trace
tranquillement ou des bus n'est pas
ultra attentif ou si c'est pour
connaître ses singles des petites
actions qui fait que tu t'en vas dans
cette danse est d'assaut dans ce chemin
et le bain c'est prendre sauf qu'ici tu
as déjà vu ou déconnecté reconnaît
rapidement ce comportement là c'est
c'est une double fonction exacte avant
la force de dire saucisse c'est ça
demande beaucoup de force
reconnaître ce que tu veux puisque tu
veux popcap a dédié cette relation là où
cette personne le m'apporte pas ce que
je veux dans la vie c'est pour moi un
type parce que c'est excitant raconté
une nouvelle personne cette excellente
et les débits des relations pis la
personne plâtrerie babelway mais d'être
capable de dire non qui émousse que je
viens ici parce que j'ai pas facile
c'est pas facile déjà nous attendre à ce
moment plaisir et c'est bien cool que
vous êtes quelle forme allait tout mais
sictom pillon réseaux numériques tough
puis c'est zéro facile puis mais je
pense c'est à dire est ce que tu as
envie que ça change que pour toi flou
pour toi le staut est plus heureux là
dans le lac
je veux dire faire pour toi sinon je
voudrais tu as toi c'est ta
responsabilité et moi je pense que tout
le monde mais ça c'est la responsabilité
de de kiev avec qui se tiennent deux
ou s'ils sortent le soir chf
saura-t-elle place et que ces personnes
on est tout le temps la marde jeter qui
régissent ce qui me suit c'est plate
maire de sortir avec deux autres
personnes avec qui tu aimes et à
entendre
puis c'est d'avoir le courage d'en
parler aussi je savais en direct avec
ces personnes là pour tes l'exemple de
consort à tel endroit ou fait tout le
temps seul moyen pour ce jeu temps de
consultation avec vous mais si vous
continuez à faire ce bain je viendrai
pas la prochaine fois tout simplement
tirs rapportent
puis tout a parlé calmement puis pas
dans le jugement à puissant pas de
reproche aux autres non plus jusqu'à
compter sur comme à droite sans vraiment
immense la clé d'aborder tous les tous
les conflits ou les problèmes pas de
poids et en disant ce que toi tu fais
toi moi je dois fait ça mais quand toi
tu fais ça moi ça me fait me sentir
comme ça la partie de la décision de te
revient tu veux continuer à agir de
cette façon là sachant que moi je me
sens comme ce bain s'est affaissé et
puis moi ça me rend malade derrière les
lakers puis métier l'autre côté de la
haie mais de la manade l'amista non mais
des fois tu y vas blonde à m'diq anti
facebook et je me sens même c'est
tellement pas mon intention peut-être
mettront peut décoder certaines choses
que j'ai pas dit que nous en ferons pas
trop souvent tranchées s'est par exemple
je dois dire que quand c'était le truc
ben j'aime pas si je me sens intimidée
par thomas howell a vu mais c'est un
triste soir à intriquer fois que c'est
une émotion que ça doit partir de c'est
comme si je te laisse l'opportunité de
me demander ce qu'il faut de ceux ci
passeront dans une catégorie de mots qui
est intrigué puis c'est important de
dire si ces deux choses la communication
c'est pas important je pense que
justement camatte ont tous dit ce bain
et où si tu décides que satisfaite fait
sentir comme c'est bien une chose qui
soit à partir du site c'est toi qui
décide d'être là dedans mais de pointer
la personne du doigt c'est toi qui me
fait ressentir ces émotions là c'est moi
qui choisis me sentir comme c'est
d'abord
mais comment on peut trouver une façon
pour justement éviter ce simplement
petit engagés pour des stations vraiment
bon mais c'est ce qui est important
séparait les deux puis pied déjà qu'ils
sont encore bien meilleurs elle voulait
rester
mais ça c'est ce genre de conversation
le sait le genre de conversation
j'aurais vraiment aimé écouter plutôt
dans ma vie ouais entendu six coups mais
je pense que ça devrait être quelque
chose qui est tout simplement appris
dans les écoles quitter ou qui montrent
bien comment ces gros matches réencoder
babel temps à rire je pense c'est
quelque chose qui serait ce pas
important de mairie de kant et quand les
plus jeunes de comprendre qu est-ce qui
t'appartient puis qu'est-ce qui
appartient aux autres c'est si lui
décident de forcer comme chemin les
stups affecté par ce décès heureusement
mais crise en grèce qui n'arrête pas de
dire c'est peut-être acquis mais c'est
toi qui décide d'être cassée par ce
travail sur toi mais je pense qu'il est
moche parce qu'ils devraient faire des
crocs comme ceux déjà des cours de
psycho communication maintenant il
existe une autre formule se pose-t-il
bons termes mais s'appelle communication
consciente et ou communication non
violente qui appelle julien console
parce que non violente rixe apporte tout
de suite d'un antécédent mais moi j'ai
une amie qui m'a va faire une formation
en communication consciente
puis une formation initiatique d'une fin
de semaine puis celle un peu que j'ai
pris mi mai et base n'est pas la matière
la théorie puis ça monsieur aujourd'hui
tout à 1,26 la foule comme un spin-off
marie-mai gb - de près de proue sur les
épaules parce que tu prends plus les
problèmes des autres dans ce sens que je
vois plus maintenant je comprends que
sur ce que lui fait qu'il me fait sentir
demain que moi je vitales telles
émotions 20,6 à partir puis le chemin
qui se sont mobilisés besoin d'occuper
qui aiment communication non-violente
communication consciente c'est un homme
qui s'appelle la famille rosenberg qui a
participé à un jeu théorisé ce point
exact qui je ne connais pas beaucoup
présent sur lui mais bref il ya d'iliad
et des séances de ceux de communication
non violente qu'une qu'elles sont
conscientes qu'il ya un groupe qui
s'appelle être consciente a qui font des
conférences à montréal qu'à québec
puis c'est incroyable ces gens là c'est
fou le puy - justement du ma force et
mon ami antoine desrochers qui va faire
c'est mon anniversaire c'est peut-être
trois ans ultime on est tous le talent
cnrj vacances pas en chicane pu parce
que oui c'était à moi je commence à
ressentir quelque chose la boule que tu
parlais tantôt banque indienne trop
grosse je vais en parler de suite j'ai
comme d'abord à être tous du temps du
menu du marché de paris tout l'espace
pour mutation à voir qui peut refaire ça
soit on en parle
finie même si c'est vraiment une chance
puis trente ans de maturité à ce niveau
là que j'ai rarement vu pour un
donnant 10 par jeunes encore qui moi
c'est ça ça demande une maturité ça
demande aussi mettre son ego de côté
donnant par là soit pire ennemi depuis
2008 il a pour le prochain 10 premiers
acteurs que j'ai vu à la télé qui m'a
vraiment donné envie de faire ce pour
quoi
et mon dieu très bonne question je me
suis qu'il y ait semaine beaucoup marqué
ça j'ai vu mourir avec toi fait d'autres
victimes
quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais avec
tout au long de ma vie j'ai comme vu ses
projets piaggio mettre tout le temps et
l'énergie qu'ils dégagent et puis
l'homme a neigé qu'un bon commencé à
m'intéresser vers d'autres acteurs qui
faisait des projets plus plus
film d'auteur des trucs un peu plus
sérieux plus dramatique et tout pimenté
déjà commencé à intéresser par lui par
ses entrevues puis l'homme qui est
devenu très spirituel je suis venu
briser les fenêtres
c'est après après le suicide de sa
blonde je pense après le suspense que sa
copine s'est suicidé stu vrai il ya
quand même fait une grosse dépression
puis il commence à peindre comme
retourne à l'intérieur puis on a ceux
qui comme disparus un genre de 2,1
il revenait qu'une grosse barbe me
réinventer un peu ouais ouais enfin
c'est ce que s'est passé on avait aucune
du temps qui puis lucet se dit que le
gosse d'ouest en est mais pis je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ça pour
devrait cesser de peau c'est de mettre
de côté puis on espère un de livres là
dessus que moi j'ai jamais lu mais c'est
sûr qu'il y en a plein le tube les
forums des vidéos des gens qui parlent
de sous peu importe pis ça vaut
tellement la peine quand tu arrives à
aller enlever le plus le plus gros des
gouttes à l'intérieur de toile c'est
comme un riff tellement agréable c'est
sûr je parlais mais jamais été donné
c'est parce qu'il s'est éteint échoue
dans sa vie avant cela la formation qui
ont enfin non parce que lui il avait
juste pas comment lui en a entendu
parler mais
cette formation est déjà avant qui je
suis connecté avec au bout depuis on
s'est dit vraiment avec les gens partout
autour de moi avec qui je m'entends bien
puisque j'aime soit dans la même
dynamique que moi et derniers sont
ouvertes y installer ses yeux puis lui
en acheter une maison ensemble de moi je
lui ai habité deux seules lui aussi
pierre bonelli dont ces différents blogs
créés sont de vrais gamers habitants
semblent satan s'apprennent pas
quelqu'un qui ont acheté une maison
ensemble les deux facs pour cette raison
là aussi très dur au lendemain ainsi
qu'en marge de l'ept avec toi pour un
bail que genre sinon il faut que j'en
conviens de la place
j'avoue c'est un gros projet sans la
conjointe peter falk est mort chier tout
le monde et comme alors votre copain
monsieur d'hiroshi je commets oui car
quand je voyais on est bien situé à
l'ailé à reculons s'attendait à lesquin
qui t'a donné cette aide comme on
highway
mais j'imagine un soutien surtout quand
quelqu'un quitte elle impose me dis
qu'ils proposent méthode bénéfice est
mon exact pipi c'est qu'en fait je me
suis posé la question aussi est ce que
ma communication besoin d'être amélioré
ouais mais relation autour de moi pis je
peux sentir du tout si je pense que tout
le temps un peu toujours t'améliorer je
pense même et j'avais pas de conflit qui
était qui partait de la fête
j'essaie toujours été super important
pour moi la communication avec ma
famille mes amis et tous jalili conflit
quelques de jeu je déteste des tests de
pêche du conflit ne puis donc si seul
fait que je pose la question est ce que
j'ai besoin d'être là puis la réponse
qu'ils n'en ont pas vraiment un titre
que ça va super bien
qu'il le ferait puis gt3 jouera plus
cette fin de semaine passée de 8 à 5
mètres en jean sans peur ni le pistolet
dans la presse ces pommes et m
je pense qu'il ya des idées a précédé
formation plus approfondie qui pourrait
te demandes ce mets mais moi c'était
juste comme on partait le matin à 9h
pour fait ce choix comme 3,4 après midi
pendant deux ou trois jours je me suis
mis trop puis je suis sorti de là puis
je remercie encore aujourd'hui de
m'avoir fait ce cadeau là parce que
c'est comme ça m'a suivie aujourd'hui
peut tellement tellement bien
puis j'ai vraiment vu mes relations
s'améliorer puis non c'est moi mais moi
j'ai vu aussi plaints des charges que
vous êtes un taux de moins
ceci quand j'ai compris à me connaître
aussi moi et m'a traversé heures puis
c'était une super bénéfique ça me donne
envie de faire ce qu elle se souhaite
alerter les gens sur quatre adil ça vaut
vraiment la peine je t'enverrai les
infos ce tueur il vous plaît non pour
faire ce temps mentionné yes men tantôt
ouais j'en ai parlé
justement avec mention bien on s'est vus
puis les semaines derrière les
apparences de comédie le c'est beau
c'est beau vraiment c'est vraiment un
film qui qui ont une vie au delà du 2
heures en riant 2 à la réalité coutelier
+10 plus profond qu'on vraiment
l'ensemble le film - je me suis content
quand la vive la première fois
maastricht on en a parlé avec mx m'avait
dit genre pour dire que je dise plus wii
le jeu
probablement que si c'etait pas les
semaines je serai pas là parce que tu es
à partir du de ce moment la piste venait
de le revoir en plus parce que avant
qu'on parte c'est d'homme qui m'avait
challenge est d'aller aux auditions qui
dans le fond on était en voyage à taïwan
mais juste avant de partir en voyage
j'avais revu le film part j'en avais
parlé avec job avant que nos acquis je
venais juste de revoir le film puis je
m'étais dit ok là j'ai fini de macaluso
genre fait que là je veux dire oui plus
que lui me proposer ce jeu fait hacker
mengo la bosse aussi la bosse des kamas
qui mène tu veux que je fasse un exposé
oral devant québec au complet qui peut
jouer à gauche puis servait des fois
d'avoir regretté décision s'est jusqu'à
maintenant mais je me suis quand même
garder certains noms mais ben oui puis
je pense que c'est ce qu'on apprend dans
le film si c'est exact
tout le temps que se disent même le
gourou dit oui je le dis aussi aussi
cette affaire que moi j'ai dû travailler
que le temps de dire non ouattara 10 mai
s'est s'établi son président non pas par
la réaction des autres mais encore une
fois ça leur appartient la réaction si
vous décidez de forget pour sa question
à discuter dans le temps que tu fais du
temps ces personnes là tu as tu été
méchant avec elle ou peu importe sinon
tout juste répondu non il y aurait
vraiment sous titre 18 de thomas mais le
site doit de travailler surtout même que
ça t'affecte pas aussi décidé de
franchir une coche
puis c'est un travail souci les deux cd
bon défi pour des raisons différentes
les battre les deux mains et dire oui
une situation mettant qui challenge ans
mais qui étaient parentes piqué qui est
un des films qui sont de confessions si
oui c'est dit oui à ce mets une
situation justement qui va t'amener
absolument rien juste une négatif dit
non à prendre on associe d'être capables
de reconnaître ces situations le oui
parce que les situations qui paraissent
par un confortable mais dans le fond
c'est juste parce que c'est un bon défi
ce foutu 18 capes dit oui à ces choses
le temps prend tellement tu avances
tellement de travail ça déplace que tu
aurais jamais imaginé rendent le témoin
je prétends pas l'expert du oui mais
quand quelque chose quelque chose mettra
les outils mettons je me fais demandé
c'est en tout je fais de la musique tpiy
je me fais dire ok dans trois jours il y
aurait tel show photo ap rennes 40
tonnes
alpha puis ja je vous masser puis je
vais dire oui est capable de le faire je
vous dis oui
maranger je me suis ramassé manager de
cette place genre à faire des dac vocaux
pour ginette reno même pas ce que j'ai
dit oui à des affaires que j'en
connaissais le fcg finit bien après
c'est la dream qui était de com image je
réparais de faire ce métier j'ai des
fêtes pis fini oui vraiment vraiment
tout à fait rejeter si le podcast sujet
on l'avait dit oui c'est moi si j'avais
pas dit oui moi aussi c'est quelque
chose qui me faisait peur c'est pas une
situation parce que je me disais genre
je vraiment à l'aise là dedans ça va
être facile
tchijov ça marche c'est comme n'importe
quoi qui s'approchaient de la radio fait
un peu de radio jean remettait des
musiques genre on continue avec tel
tournoi mais là tu as écouté les midis
jazz c'est exactement entre au point 6
non non mais c'est ça mais parce que
c'est en faisant aussi que tu empruntes
dia meilleurs titres
c'est juste demain sur les enfants du
coup moi je pense que on a tout comme
une boussole à l'intérieur de nous un
instrument qui donne le site arrive à
l'écouté avec le temps dan amman et ce
il vaudrait dire lui c'est bon pour toi
ou non il s'est laissé le petit toit
puis défaut cds portant pas de mélanger
le stress avec la fébrilité methot ou
des trucs c'est comme moi je sais par
exemple un bon exemple pour moi ça a été
le scénario diane 54 que je trouvais
super difficile parce que j'étais
vraiment indécis à le faire ou non ce
scénario là parce que j avais des scènes
de nudité dans la pression de scénario
avec un autre cap il fallait que
j'embrasse deux autres gosses enseigne
au pij mais j'avais jamais voici de
gauche pas guy d'envy pis je me faisais
pas d'alliance faisons le
puisqu'au pas non plus dans la bible
c'est à cause d'un courant je suis
asthmatique mois afin que cet agrément
que j'apprenne encore et pour ça aussi
qui j'étais super c'est très silencieux
par rapport à ça mais il y avait une
petite voix intérieure moi c'est ainsi
que ça peut être bon pour tous de
celui-ci mais c'est juste que c'est à
faire le sale gosse mais ça vient en
ville c'est comme si tu arrives à eau -
entreprendre cette rue club savoir en
bout de ligne c'est avoir la peine puis
super content d'avoir fait aujourd'hui
des gens que j'ai rencontrés là tu peux
travailler avec yann ça a été ça a été
super super formateur je pense pour moi
une certaine façon tant à l'intérieur
d'une école secondaire devant les jeunes
de l'école factice pas un plateau ferme
il moi je suis juste un bail en coin le
pit sors de ton courte une voie puis les
gens viennent me voir pimp appuyé par
les juifs aux jeunes par exemple je me
trompe et je tournais ferme montech dans
la tête et tout fait que c'était super
difficile de me concentrer c'est à
nouveau pour moi c'est aussi ce que je
fais au parfum d'antan mais ça aide ça a
été super bien fait pour moi mettons sur
il s'est regardé mettons tout de garder
la course
oui un peu des fois frenchy des gones en
[Rires]
mai la cour soit j'ai gardé ça puis j'ai
réussi à acheter
améliorer ma concentration ma bulle en
fait quand je travaille je gueulais
c'était vraiment être tout le temps
challenge et le par des dégâts qui sont
pas tendres de devoir encore nicole avec
un cadavre devant toi parce que si les
kings de l'école maintenant l'appui de
voir arriver le put être les filles très
porteur puissants comme fait chier moi
j'étais un peu sur la jalousie ou peu
importe ils vont envoyer chier de loin
ils vont inciter déconcentrés ils vont
piquer les affaires entre les gens mais
en avait de tulle
ouais j'en avais d'être ce puits se sent
moins seul travail même du travail et
puis aussi a quand même bloqué depuis je
pense que c'est pas bon pour moi
aujourd'hui
ouais ça fait partie du bagage mais fait
pour revenir à ce qu'on sait sur le
temps j'ai dit oui je le savais puis
c'est sûr je pense qu'on sait
généralement c'est quand même preneur à
se prononcer sur 6 6 à la fin de séance
par coup mais quelque chose qu'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche
moi je pense être encore qui arrivent
déjà anticipé des problèmes qui
pourraient causer des conflits au
printemps il sait que c'est peut-être un
peu de ça peut tout changer aussi moi je
pense et je pense avaient toujours fini
par changer mais fera confiance au
feeling quelque chose que tu files peu
oui ça peut être aussi quelque chose qui
cloche ans a fallu que vous soyez pas
toi qui concordent pas mais j'ai dans ma
carte de natation j'ai réussi à séparer
le stress plus l'excitation stress
négatif
la fébrilité qui une fois que j'ai
compris la différence entre ces deux
émotions là j'ai vraiment plein step
mental sur sur mes performances
guéant répond je me levais le matin
compétition pis quand je sentais c'est
la même genre de boule dans l'estomac
mais quand je la sentais et comme étant
du stress j'étais pas bien quand j'ai
quand je me suis levé un matin puis j'ai
fait un peu le seul parce que j'aime ce
au final ce que je mange forfait que
c'est humain
est-ce que je suis stressé ou juste
excité de ce que je m'en vais faire les
fêtes crise je d'exister georges et or
d'aller faire ça puis il la boule dans
mon estomac est pas négatif
finalement est positive d'après ce
apprécié du port avec cette espèce
d'idée l'hôpital tout juste un système
positif sur tout l'été
ceci ça c'est dans n'importe quoi qui
sortent de la zone de confort si si
vraiment ce que tu ressens vraiment
comme une espèce d'anxiété des cas même
temps je n'ai aucune envie de le faire
ceux des x force c'était juste pour tous
les citoyens espèce de boule qui dit
amène quelque chose là il ya une boule
dans mon ventre mais j'ai peut pas
vraiment dire que c'est parce que ça me
tente pas c'est de l'écouté aussi mais
le phare la distinction ça permet de
voir des expériences comme ceux plus
possible de pas de priver aussi de
marijuana
c'est exact et 14 sur le scénario de ma
biche oh my way de boule dans le ventre
un genre de sa fiche à la hauteur quand
j'ai reçu le scénario on la construit sa
vie l'écrivain chez lui puis me parlait
déjà des cinq équipes avaient déjà taxés
comme build up c'est ce faire j'imagine
que tout acteur si c'est le rêve de tout
acteur de ce genre de rôle la fin si
j'imagine pas trop hésité à dire oui
non non j'ai 18 sauf que nous gérons ces
pamphlets de yes man oui il devrait
quand même avoir une part associés à ces
excès
mais cette parle des fois je la vois en
ayant le scénario pour la première fois
comme ça au fur et à mesure que j'ai lu
le scénario
toutes les scènes du personnage que j'ai
incarné le temps je vais me mettre à la
place il a juste d'imaginer en tête
comment je les ferai ce que je conforte
à la france et ça ne leur est tout
simplement tout est ce que je me pense
que vous êtes bon pour la faire puis
puis oui là des fois je vais avoir comme
du trajet en bus pour embarquer ou la
pomme étant virtuellement qui n'ont
peut-être pas ce que j'ai vu est trop
d'affaires avec lesquels je suis pas à
l'aise et où j'ai mes pas me tendre
simplement et des rôles qui est à
crittenden à cause que les quelque chose
qui te retenir
ouais ouais ou parce que des fois c'est
jésus dit par les mamies j'ai travaillé
comme un malade joueurs c'est comme j'ai
travaillé sur deux quotidiennes c'était
il y avait subi des textos les argonauts
et 3 répète le lundi est mort dix petits
tourner le mercredi jeudi vendredi
mérite des textes mais trotec selon
vraiment épais depuis sa clôture cette
semaine qui comme au bouquet après ce
que j'avais certaines journées sur le
télérama mémoire vive
puis après si je te donne même prendre
ce train de préparer pour moi me même si
comme j'adore le tartare de saumon c'est
fatigant mais tous les jours en valais
jeu tekken faqih je trouve ça plate
parce que parce que justement j'ai
tellement passionné par ce que je
retournais chez nous plutôt comment s'y
prendre
dia les domaines dont tu peux laisser
trop trop trop ça que j'ai commencé
comme vraiment faire acquis il faut que
je reprenne pour true gens prennent
voici donc des foyers des rôles que je
veux tout simplement
refuser parce que j'ai la fenps erreur
qui me manque beaucoup d'énergie puis là
je prends du temps pour moi te jure
comme moi est capable de me re me
replier en énergie puis c'est aussi que
si je le pense le scénario puis je les
sens pétanque sopi je sais que je vais
être fatigué pas je revenais de tel
tournage à ce moment là ben je vais pas
arriver sur le set puis que lui le
personnage qui m'en faire ben je tends
la main du comprends c'est comme moi je
suis pas bon pour ce rôle parce que je
vais être brûlé en revenant je pense que
quelqu'un d'autre qui devrait avoir la
chance de le faire puis qui lui vaut
falloir mettre toute l'énergie petit
l'espace et est-ce que tu t'en demande
beaucoup en ce moment on demande à ce
que ce que quand on aurait quand même à
lodève qui dit non à des affaires je dis
mon oreille pas complètement l'eau des
puits encore de la place pour un projet
qui serait super existants serait matin
c'est surtout le temps de la place pour
un projet super excitant c'est tu dis là
tu dirais peut-être non je suis fatigué
ça dépend des fois ce cas tu es déjà le
temps
déjà attaché au projet depuis un bout le
tarif le plomb du même instrument la
fiorano projet qui là encore plus
excitant ben c'est sûr que c'est juste
quand un engagement pour moi c'est
qu'elles respectent le pays veut pas que
le maître loeb d'armada trouver un
nombre un nouveau à castet de nouvelles
personnes pour le rôle c mais c'est une
question de circonstances je pense tout
simplement s'il voit ce que parce que tu
es le plus envie d'aller tous ouais
ouais mais ses coups et je te dirais que
depuis depuis mon mais justement
conservateur parce qu'on a beaucoup de
rôles c'est sûr les gens pensent à moi
puis non seulement ce même moi quand
j'arrive sur un plateau tournant je veux
que les gens ont envie de retravailler
avec moi je trouve ça le fun moore puis
je suis aux femmes pour moi aussi et
puis je pense que c'est ce qui fait
travailler déjà quand même assez
longtemps dans leur carrière
à voir comment je te demande tu traites
les relations tapas international bbi
travail.suisse culture ce n'est pas moi
tu es dans une personne n'avait keith
taylor de travailler ensemble
c'est clair j'ai une question qui m'est
venue à 88 des petites des aspirations
derrière la caméra un peu mou non eh
ouais ouais j'en ai rigolé quel genre la
musique je commencerai moi je commence à
explorer la musique un peu et cela
maintenant j'ai commencé avec des cours
de piano quand j'avais peut-être en
gaspésie chemin que j'ai pas entretenu
avec le temps mais que je vous retourne
chercher j'ai construit drôme plan ouais
je vais commencer commencé à prendre des
cours de chant aussi je te dis qu'au
début mon buste elle est capable de
générer du monde tout simplement
quand bak sa guise ben moi je suis pas
marqué sur le drame juste taper sur un
bas limitent depuis le même si de faire
de la guilde ou six factions la musique
est quelque chose que je commence à
explorer mais pas nécessairement en tant
que le frontman comme artiste le juste
jouer la musique d'abord d'abord c'est
pour - kaboré faire la musique et
colombie puis pour moi aussi après ce
les par les cours de chant
ma me falek chante je vous parlais 700
lettres incroyables
puis le dreg le personnage alors stressé
mais toi tu voulais dire été aussi des
lavages monsieur je veux dire que david
melody je sais je sais pas chanter et
c'est parfait c'est exactement ce qu'il
sait pas chanter yeux rieurs franck
innocenti gens c'est comme si tout petit
puis venu chanter pour sa mère puis
c'est bon même qu'il faut c'est en
chantant puis jeté caddies c'est bon
sens et m'en parle
c'est vraiment un bon film que tu vois
aussi l'amour des xavier pour le québec
puis la culture dans une course pareille
dans ce film le dit si bien il laisse
pas de taille passé non ces recherches
men pirouette théâtre là dessus de moi
aussi je vous parlais moi jouer chez
nous le cacher j'ai vraiment été
justement là céline latitude pour si je
suis sûr qu'ils habitent sur céline 112e
des grills ouais c'est beau sauter
xavier autant que t on le sait qui a été
amicale payer de livres faites aux
femmes aux états unis pseu mais tu ça
paraît dans ces femmes qu'il ya un amour
pour lesquelles ces autres moments forts
et au québec ces crises il
mais à chaque fois qu'on me demande
mettons la première chose que je
montrerai à quelqu'un qui veut découvrir
le québec c'est super ok je serai et
claude croesi parce que parce que s'il
sait que le québec comme comme il sait
le québec québec des années 110 80 90
comme nous on est nés afin de te
laitiers l'espèce les partenaires et je
les reconnais ses partenaires de chez ma
grand-mère le gie à l'élitiste est gelée
vécu maintenant 2 - team est ce
quelqu'un me demande
d c'est quoi le film prend forme mieux
le connaître le québec je dirais je
dirais creuzil ci-après souviendrai
momie tout de suite après puis ça c'est
le fun justement de voir des
réalisateurs internationaux québécois
qui sont dans le deuil national guard et
ce même si le ch c'est clair qu'il
aimait tant
jean marc vallée il participe un petit
bois depuis je peux aussi vous revenir
au québec non je l'espère puis mais
xavier genre de voir son prochain
waikiki revenus tous les buteurs j'ai
pas vu la version qu'ils vont montrer à
4 j'ai vu une première version 2d
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce petit gars ben hibon
gaby gamme c'est la personne font les
bons amis c'est quand même il va pas
marcher puis puis tout le monde est bon
dans le film puis le sait comme il ya
comme un groupe d'amis qu'on a construit
son vers un peu puis cette énergie le
cul qui a réussi à passer car sacré en
fait avec toutes ces personnes est
magique vraiment manger quoi musique
regarder c'est vraiment de beaux
sourires vraiment vraiment vraiment
changé leur succès à cannes sont en ce
moment c'est loin c'est le sait quand ça
sort si ce qui comprend le jeu je pense
ça va dépendre de comment ça va se
passer comme si gagne des fois je pense
que si tu gagnes tromperie de jurés ou
peu importe où le où le prix la palme
d'or si je pense que ça va les
distributeurs ils vont évaluer le marché
en fonction d'être ce qu'est ce qui est
le mieux pour l'assurer satisfait mais
tout ça peut affecter ce je pense que
j'adore ce gars est la personne la plus
drôle que j'y rencontre c'est vraiment
fort et jean la personne la plus drôle
c'est cette affaire dans vraie vie les
mêmes qui pensent stand-up les gens dans
son personnage 100 % et dans les
prochains jours le film peut être vu le
la baule ouais y'a peut-être même déjà
joints qui bêche je pense comment ça
faudrait sûrement vu passer des
critiques moi c'est sûr il va alors la
première projection qui est je pense
qui c'est qui où est en même temps que
la première mais je suis allé là
dangereux en ce moment tu shootes dans
cool en ce moment je shoote
je voudrais en soit la nature de ces
métaux non- géant j'ai des propositions
qui ont qui sont pas encore signé mais
qui intéresse les prochains ce qui nous
a parlé sur les josh hartnett qui est
pilote
ouais ça gâte nsync ça devrait manquer
c'était au tour du mois de septembre
je pense qu'ils veulent te décides
relatif avec moi donc ce mais ça va
sortir en 2010 neuf pour moi cela ira
concours c'est l'histoire d'un québécois
qui s'appelle alain ollivier qui dans
les années 90 il était jeune john qui en
fait lui il ya eu des partis en
thaïlande avec un ami puis c'est un
utilisateur dayraut puis je pense qu'ils
en ont ramené avec eux au canada puis là
comme par les 1 go pour mission mauvaise
personne qui était je pense on informe
en temps pour la police ou puisqu'un pas
le terme exact
bref ici il ya une grosse opération qui
s'est faite monter autour de lui en
pensant que c'était 1-1 du rgs lors
d'une entrevue qui avait des très bonnes
connexions dans le codeem trois gros
qu'on appelle qui qui aidé en font une
région entre trois pays dont la
thaïlande qui je pense que c'est le kiss
et deuxième plus gros producteur de
dévoyer fait que penser qu'avec de
cavernes collection directement avec
ceux enfin qui ont commencé à construire
l'opération autour de lui puis à
mi-chemin sont rendus compte qu'ils
avaient pas le bong wc tromper notre
famille je pense ou peu importe puisque
je rends chez john qu'il y avait 25
années je pense que c'est toi ce
tempérament je me suis fait le
personnage dans la villa dans la pile
journaliste vite en mal à recques de
toronto je pense quitte un vrai
journaliste lui entendu parler
d'histoire le puits et distille un
vestige et s'est allié en thaïlande
rencontre est allé en prison
puis tant pis elle abrita reprises
d'abord qui s'est faite en présence
là-bas vie c'est sans fin sans censure
le haut lieu de vente allant entre en
thaïlande en une saison tournée à bord
puis il ya surtout prison à 97 machine
est à 90 sera très drôle plus revenu
québec alain puis je les rencontrer
avant le tournage super gentil legault
j'ai beaucoup d'amour maintenant il
reste en prison
il restait huit ans l'espérance de vie
ces sept ans on taille dans les prisons
d'abord puis est exposé il y avait été
d'enfants condamnés à mort que chez eux
il ya pied décide pas des coupables pour
qu'il soit une sentence de cent ans au
lieu d'un an exactement fait que le
suisse est sauvée en faisant ce parce
que le but i'm alive commencé à l'aider
à récolter toutes les papiers pour
prouver qu' il n'y a pas d'enfant le
fait que lyon décide fargo financier
puis daniel roby lui a suivi dans une
partie sur le puits à suivre tout le
procès d'alain je pense que durant une
dizaine d'années à peu près ils
suffisants en cours en chacun des d un
guetteur prouve à chaque étape je pense
puis pillay a construit ces scénarios le
puits côtiers
ça fait près de dix ans et ceux qui
travaillent là dessus il y avait
d'autres personnes qui avaient été casté
posa pas marcher tout puis ça faisait je
pense comme 3 1 qui essaient de partir
le tournage puis ça marche et jamais non
puis j'ai déjà été déjà attaché au
projet eau à ce moment là janet frame
resteront tous ces malades toutes leurs
rencontres et cela ne plaît pas jake
allen
bah oui et puis on se voit accorder foi
ses 8 ans cinquantaine qui vaut mieux il
va très bien et puis là il ya écrit et
at on écrit son livre y en a déjà qui
rit je pense tous évidemment avec
l'écrit chp se remet mais là je sais
qu'il travaille sur un livre qui va
sortir en même temps que le film qui
parle en détail de son expérience en
prison la boîte à gants même alan
labrosse et si je pense j'avais vu ça
sur une liste que c'était jean la 18e
pires prisons dans le monde
hospitalisée la banque one en thaïlande
et à la fête de en fait mais bon coin
celle là c'est un hippie ce qu'ils font
c'est quand tu arrives tu es nouveau ils
prennent des gros morceaux métal qui
publie autour de tajan avec une machine
qui supportent seuls ces chaînes comme
je sais pas combien dizaine de livres
entre les auges fait ce n'est pas poli
et entre aux premiers mois c'était
gentil tu es enlève sinon été laisse lui
avait gardé pendant six mois je pense
qu'ils sur trois une prison thaïlandaise
de personnes qui parlent français la
mole cécilia nec par francis et du monde
comme lui qui sont fait arrêter là bas
au pied puis c'est vraiment des
conditions qui sont difficiles puis on
l'y voit justement traîner dans le film
les pieds d'el pour consommation et
possession parce qu'ils pensaient que
c'était le doivent leur nom parce que
dans le fond eux ils voulaient organiser
l'opération là-bas thaïlande pour le ton
je sais pas combien de kilos dayraut qui
plus le kilo être plus le nombre des
kilomètres dans transaction était au
plus haut
c'était dit faisait payer charles puis
pillu dans le fond il sait juste qu'il
ya comme parler à son ami ou un c qui
mettons le gars qu'il adore foi et a
défendu à l'oeil essayé ma chaque fois
ci cambi voulait pas et voulait de
laisser aux opi justement de ce que de
ce qu'on comprend c'est que y'a ils
l'ont dit et la pression mr b qu'on
appelle perso mr big que la pousse la
police fait passer pour comme une mafia
un peu le tout l'opération mister
duration mr big mess et ceci c'est un
type de stratégie je pense yeux et non
pas le prénom pas le nom de cette
opération le quai ouais ça va être du
sud préparent pour un rôle comme seul
puis tu fais des recherches puis que tu
pars à cette personne là ça t'amène ça
doit amener en une place unique en
est-il
ben oui ceci dit tu parles augure je
peux même pas concevoir ckoi passé huit
ans dans un dans un trou misérable moi
j'ai passé trois mois dans une île de
danse ville de luxe à bali j'étais tanné
en tabarnak ont accès à 100 voire
contact avec ma famille je t'ai coeur et
des tripes c'est qu'on parle
jesuslesfilles une journée cette semaine
et fait quatre ans de magie et était
loin de chez vous ils ont même pris 161
personnes qui il ne peut pas rentrer en
contact et que personne ne la boll tout
le monde parte à landelles et ici ça
normal y avait quelque chose
d'incroyable puis je pense que de faire
un film du devoir seul d'avoir son petit
on va se faire partager à travers un
film avec farine janet
ben oui mais je pense que ce cessez je
pense que c'est tout simplement la vie
qui retournent les choses autour de son
côté ou tout simplement mais je sais que
ça leur a tellement heureux que les gens
puissent connaître son histoire du
putois c'est justement disait on peut
plus imaginer c'est quoi vivre de photos
font péter byers et de comprendre c'est
quoi cette douleur le puits de le
transposer à l'écran la bible d'après
son appareil ouais j'ai acheté un peu
plus jeunes et puis j'ai regardé la télé
en gaspésie je voyais un film d'un
pompier me tombent d'accord je vais te
pompiers plutôt apprécié ce voyage avec
un peu le cipd comme facteur je vais te
policiers des taxes et jean puis amman
et j'étais incapable de décider que
j'effectue la foi qui les relient tous
extraits des films exaltent comme je
préfère ce doit être tous et c'est un
policier pendant 30 jours pour un peu
après s'être savent ce qui s'est
vraiment rizzoli signifie rencontrer
alain seghi larsson extraordinaire kiki
votre compte et l'histoire tout le temps
des nouvelles puis moi j'y ai côtoyé
longtemps pendant le tournage puis je le
vois encore défaut de pirate ou tard une
nouvelle qui fait le christ moi je me
disais qu'à vécu le pipe c'est justement
ce qu'ils font de rentrer dans la peau
de ce personnage de piles vivre pendant
quelques quelques jours
deux se désiste de le mettre dans les
culottes des autres pc de comprendre en
fait sur ce vraiment un privilège en
fait oui puis c'est ça fait un peu un
cercle complet parce qu'on comparait
tantôt d'être capable de comprendre les
autres
tessa parce que si toi tu y trouves ton
travail et si de constamment être
capable de comprendre une réalité qui
n'est pas la sienne
ça prend beaucoup plus ouverts à
comprendre des réalités qui sont
policiers pour boucler la boucle aussi
doit-on parler de ce concentré de se
confronter à des situations très
difficiles ou des émotions difficiles
pour apprendre a dealé avec les gérer de
s'épiler cinéma je pense peut vraiment
nous aider à faire ce type à ce que si
le cinéma c'est pas rien et était le
cinéma divertissement qui vont être les
avengers climatique doit faire l'homme
et toute une gamme de cinéma qui vont
être parfois moins évident au regard des
outils de confronter des émotions petit
film et qui vont à la fin du film
d'avoir fait vivre des choses d'avoir
transporté d'avoir fait voir quelque
chose de nouveau que tu avais jamais vus
avant vivre surtout de nouveaux vols
abondent à travers les yeux de quelqu'un
d'autre ce lycée ça peut vraiment des
autres c'était ou où vivre ces bétons
mettant de jamais vécu deuil dans ta vie
tu te remets perricone proche de toi ben
si tu là un petit peu véhicules à
travers des personnages du béton ou le
premier de ce que j'ai vécu c'est une
façon d'envoyer on retrouvera t clic 1
qui est mort j'ai pleuré et puis comme
comme beaucoup d'autres sauf que à ce
moment là moi comme plein d'autres
personnes ma génération ont compris
c'est quoi le 2 c'est quoi perdre
quelqu'un une charte
puis après ça quand ça arrive tu as de
la peine mais ça n'arrive pas de nulle
part cette émotion le j'avais déjà vécu
un pour cent de ce que c'était comme
j'en avais qu mettons même pas 1% et 0
point 1 % de que ça doit être la
deuxième guerre mondiale exemple qui
était vu des films si ça permet d un
petit peu comprendre clt le doudou de ce
soit de se préparer dès à demander si
dans notre vie où on va comme ça avec le
cinéma ça vraiment des vertus verte'
cela peut nous rendre avant des
meilleures personnes comme ça et puis
j'aime j'aime je pense et je trais j'ai
beaucoup de là dessus pour avoir des
projets comme ceux là qui ce qui me sont
offertes comme mme ahmine 54 gatinska
qui sûrement sont trop projet qui parle
de décennale qui sont tous vrais de
vrais choses qu'on peut voir à entendre
parler pipi qui sont tous des sujets
aussi je pense parce qu'il ya un manque
d'amour ou un pommeau en fait c'est
juste dépenses faisant des sujets où est
ce que certaines personnes vivent ce
pilote est enfin voir un produit qui en
parle de cette réalité l'oeuvre de leur
apporter du bien une forme d'empathie
justement j'ai beaucoup de gratitude
pour sera vraiment le fait d'être
comédien mais j'en ai fait de même
j'imagine que c'est toi tous tes projets
on en a parlé meute et ont apporté
quelque chose tant fait apprendre des
choses puis tous les comédies connors ou
podcast la majorité s'est déjà ultra
mature qui comme toute espèce comme on
s'en doute est ce par jeunes ultra
mature ultra vive d'esprit de s'exprimer
keith hembre n'est venu ici s'exprime
tellement bien dit avec tant d'aisance
facilité rose-marie aussi c'est ce
milieu là mais c'est ce que je remarque
ce milieu le très vite obligé d'être
professionnel je vois en toi ça sent le
vieux tes genoux on est 12 13 ans sur
tel film pas si on besoin enfin mais les
rays l'équipe soit dix enfants 12 16
si vous êtes une famille qui ont des
enfants n'auraient pas qu'ils sont sont
occupées c'est qu'ils ont c'est soyons
pas le temps ni les autres sont là pour
travailler puis oui dans le plaisir moi
si je vois dans le plaisir tout cas moi
j'adore le travail que je fais de ses
pistes à porte puis je le fais parce que
j'aime ce que je pense
puis ça tu apprends vite à devoir être
responsable comprendre cette cette
routine loupé cette réalité là ça fait
des lits gens qui devient de fait
naturellement ramatuelle et les acteurs
je pense que je pense que c'est des gens
que j'aime beaucoup côtoyé des gens
intéressants bien métier qui te faut
soucis à devoir entamer en version de
toi-même tout le temps d être la
meilleure possible à chaque scène à
chaque moment il y aura ce que quatre
une équipe de 30 personnes qui qui
attendent que toi tu n'es homme d
affaires que tout se fasse une bonne
performance de cette pression là aussi
le détour mais ton quand tu composes
dans un studio de marne at on tout seul
pour capitale tchèque 6 à 30 personnes
qui sont tour à tour dans leur sac pour
ma part tout droit le jeu pendant arrivé
à plusieurs d'entre nous sur pilotis pas
comme afin que ces gens je sais que
telle personne vote for me remplace en
ce moment le popoli parce que c'est là
si ça vienne coûte état à la politique
charge plus aujourd'hui mais quand même
ça me fait capoter les exagérant depuis
les gentils après si tu montes tu es
plus qu'un point qu'on sait qu'ils
arrivent à octobre et baissent mais ces
deux-là mot même effectivement tu peux
partir ou juste de sortir la veille par
exemple tarifs scrap soir si ce n'est
qu'ils font le pire est que c'est leur
choix mais mais je pense que c'est une
forme de respect que moi me ton jeu mais
je me couche tôt la veille
puis je me prépare puis j'arrive sur le
site puis j'ai hâte de faire cette série
ça fait un mois je travaille dessus mais
ton est tout puisque quelques d'accueil
et shopi avons maintenant si je serai
versailles rôle d'éclaireur les attend
s'ils s'en rende compte son assesseur
j'entends j'en entends l'histoire des x
de personnes loin d'ici aux états unis
évidemment entre autres qu'on entend
souvent mais mais je pense que c'est ce
site inverse les rôles le nous au regard
de playback puis je fais comme tabarnak
c'est normal ce faisant c'est quoi qui
ça marche pas pas en tout le pays parce
que lui décidé de faire d'apporter la
veille des voeux gestion des factures
s'ils le sont si ceux ci ne sont pas
professionnels je pense que si c'est le
moindre des choses de l'alto sites ont
causé par les tentes ou de khanfar au
kiss-in parfaite
certains de ses films l'autorité
entrevue avec seth rogen
puis il disait et il parle il parle de
sa consommation double positif cette
collection date avec ses avec stephen
colbert me semble qui dit fête tout
notre coeur dans un film est ce que
deschamps ce qui t'a donné cette scène
le faut que les gens pour cent pour cent
des chances tout le temps avec tout les
soins que vous voyez au cinéma je suis
gelé parce que c'est sa personne sa
personne sociable déduit des pages
laisserait plus de mise je pense que lui
c'est juste une combinaison gagnante
financer seule salle de bain et puis
j'adore le travail qui fait déjà dans ce
qui fait que pour lui de travailler
jeudi mais aussi ceux qu'il faut tu
arrives à faire la job mineurs portés à
man merci c'était super plaisir
si je l'espère pendant trois ans je sais
qu'il ya des zones stars qui vont être
que ça va les aider
j'espère moi savourer mais il ya une
demande afin d'attirer de france
un des deux stades européens aujourd'hui
m'intéresse pas merci les gars très
coupants adresse une longue vie au
papier merci